[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today let's go
to Mark now in Portland Oregon Mark how
can we
help hello hello Mark you're live what's
happening alrighty so I have kind of
like a weird multifaceted question um I
am a um 100% disabled veteran but I'm
still like total impermanent and I'm
still allowed to work though okay um I I
have pretty much all my GI bill bill um
and I have minimal student loan debt
from uh getting my degree and I have my
I got my bachelor's in mechanical
engineering um but kind of the big kind
of Crux to what I'm wondering is like I
get a one-time uh student federal
student loan
forgiveness uh from the because of the
nature of my disability um from being in
the Navy
um so I'm kind of like trying to see
like is it worth it to just go to grad
school and then just uh max out the
student loans and just get them forgiven
it seems kind of sketchy to me a little
bit what hold on a second hold onal hold
on hold on hold on so what what would
the Masters what would the Masters be in
and why would you get it um it would
probably be a master's in mechanical
engineering uh focused more on like
building science like building science
in the built environment that's kind of
what I'm doing now so would that set you
up for growth financially through
promotions yeah yeah it would um so what
sketchy because he has the GI
bill because I can uh use my GI Bill
that pays for the entire tuition and I
get a housing stien like if I were to be
going staying in
Portland uh I would be getting 2300
bucks a month taxfree while in school so
and then on top of oop sorry go oh go
ahead I had one more question but go
ahead and then on top of that if I were
to take out student loans I could take
out up to 65,000 a year um for the two
years um to do that to kind of offset
the loss of income that I have
now uh and then another kind of weird
aspect to this too is like this would be
like if I were to do that that would be
more than what I'm making now with the
GI Bill and those loans because there's
no taxes associated with that but um and
my wife is also in medical school right
now too so just kind
of the money is kind of fungible because
we're married but like realistically a
lot of the money would probably end up
going towards like reducing her loans so
let me get let me let me make sure I got
my head around this because some I'll be
honest like with all the military
payments and stuff like that sometimes
it get gets confusing so you've got a
little bit of existing student loan debt
how much is that yeah 10K 10K will the
GI bill pay for that pay that off no but
I could get it forgiven right now if I
wanted to but okay so just one thing at
just one thing at a time because I want
to help you but I also want to make sure
the people listening understand why
won't the GI Bill cover that because
it's he's already done that but have
that the GI bill would cover you going
to grad school correct yes so my
question is why can't you just use the
GI Bill to go to grad school if that's
what you want to do and why can't you
use the other piece that you had the
federal student loan forgiveness because
of your disability to pay off the 10,000
what's wrong with
that yeah that's kind of what I'm
thinking but to me and this is where I'm
like kind of the moral and ethical
dilemma like I could do all that but
then I could also take out more student
loans and then those would get forgiven
because it's just a one-time deal so
what you want to do you want to take out
extra student loans knowing that you can
get the federal government forgiveness
yes yes and not use those for
education I mean it would be covering my
housing expenses and all that like
that's kind of where I thought I heard
you say I thought hold on hold on hold
on hold on hold on hold on I also
thought I heard you say that would go
towards paying off some of your wife's
medical loan debt as well so you're
talking about taking out a student loan
to use personally
well you can use student loans to cover
your housing expenses but you say the GI
Bill already gave you a stipend for the
housing that's just for like living
expenses and other Portland's like a
more expensive city but hold up okay
hold on hold on hold on because I I I
I'm hearing you but I'm also feeling a
little it I'm the fact that we're going
back there is a shady quality to it
because the GI Bill covers what we would
call living expenses right like whether
that's rent or other things that goes
along with living but you're saying I
would take out student loans to continue
to do that my problem with that is the
GI Bill saying hey we have a sipon for
that that's what that money is intended
for the federal student loan forgiveness
student loans by definition should be to
pay for education so it does bother me
related expenses well no not necessarily
I mean related expenses yes but you go
are you living on campus to go to school
no no I have a house and a mortgage and
a job so that's what I'm saying like
currently so I would stop working to go
to school yeah I feel like that's a
little weird it's not like you're going
to school you're taking out student
loans this is covering rooming board and
dormatory and that I mean by they are
student loans which by the way I
wouldn't tell somebody to take out
student loans anyway but in this case
they're forgiven I
just
I'm gonna I'm so wait a second let me
and and part pardon us we're we're not
trying to be dense not it's just the way
you set this up it's strange well it's
strange because you know it's not right
that's what I think yeah it's not a
stupid so hold on so you agree that you
just said okay we finally got it I
didn't mean to lead you there this is my
first lawyer
moment you don't feel this is right uhuh
and I don't feel like it's right it is
sketchy yeah well then why are you
calling us asking us if we think you
should do something sketch cuz free
money makes you do funny things Ken well
it ain't free it's on the taxpayers back
illegal like with my friend my friend
listen to me first of all two things
since you
called now I'm G to tell you what I
think it's
sketchy because it's wrong it's wrong
yeah because you're taking out money
that is that's all taxpayer funded my
friend I'm paying for that Jade's paying
for that I could go around the room we
got some nice people out in the lobby I
don't think they would like to pay for
that either they don't feel good about
it for but my Crux of it the Crux of it
for me the reasoning behind it because I
feel like we do have to point out the
reasoning for me the reasoning is
student loans really should be for
education and I don't think in your case
I don't think the living expenses are an
expense of you getting your education if
you were going to live on campus if you
were staying in a dormatory if you had
you know get an apartment in another
city to take the classes then I could
see okay like maybe but in your case
because this is this is your situation I
don't see how your personal mortgage has
anything to do with you choosing to go
to grad school and so for that reason I
think that's where the ethical barrier
is for me um we're agreeing with you you
said it was sketchy we think it's
sketchy and and let me just say this
you're a great American you served our
country uh disability because of it
you're you're a great American you're a
great American and you know it's sketchy
so this up to you my friend I don't
think you kind of I don't think you can
rationalize this uh for me or for my
head and I haven't been able to well
then trust your gut look if you were
like if you had said something I'm just
trying to come up with some scenarios if
you were like hey when I was in the
military you I don't know I'm just
trying to come up with a way that maybe
this m like if you inquired a bunch of
other debt because of school but I just
don't see that like this just doesn't
no it done hit right you're a good man a
great American thank you for your
service your gut's right we agree with
your gut uh and and you've got a bright
future in front of you you don't need
this wife's going to get through Medical
School you guys going to be fine don't
try to shortcut it you guys are on the
right path thanks for the call this is
the Ramsey Show create your free every
dooll budget today the simplest way to
budget for your life